good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight there is a verdict in
that very depressing but also Byzantine
and interesting murder trial in South
Carolina tonight we've got Judge Jeanine
in a moment to take us through exactly
what happened and what happens next
But first you always imagined in your
mind's eye that it's evil men who
destroy a society wild-eyed spitflect
dictators pounding the podium to demand
the annihilation of their enemies that's
the Hollywood version of it but in real
life people like that really get very
far they're too obvious it's not the
cartoon demons you've got to worry about
it's weak men in positions of power
they're the most dangerous men with no
principles but the desire for
self-preservation Hollow Men who live in
Terror of being revealed for who they
really are men who will do anything to
save themselves that's who you should be
afraid of and you can see that in our
current moment the weakest are the most
destructive how much of his childhood do
you think Adam kinzinger spent hanging
from the wedgie nail how many swirlies
did Eric swalwell endure in high school
how old was Adam Schiff before a girl
other than his sister kissed him
voluntarily
it makes you shudder to think about it
these are sad insecure broken men filled
with envy and bitterness from their
lonely childhoods they hate you because
they hate themselves it's not their
masculinity that's toxic it's their lack
of it
that's really the story of the Biden
Administration the weakest president in
history joined forces with the weakest
attorney general in history to create a
police state
shocking well once you understand the
principle it shouldn't really surprise
you and it's funny now to remember that
the smart people in Washington once told
us that Merrick Garland was a moderate
they thought that apparently because
when Garland's promised Supreme Court
seat didn't materialize he cried oh he's
crying they thought he's so sensitive
and thoughtful but no
Merrick Garland was crying for himself
because he is a self-pitying careerist
with no perspectives on his own life
whose job is everything to him he is in
other words literally the last person
you would ever put in charge of the
Department of Justice so naturally Joe
Biden did and that turned out to be a
pivotal decision Merrick Garland has
presided over the most aggressive attack
on civil liberties in particular an
attack on the practice of traditional
Christianity that any living American
has seen now garland would never say
that in public of course that would be
too straightforward his approach is
feline not canine every word is a weasel
word but under sustained questioning the
real Merrick Garland emerges and it is
filthy and dishonest here he was in the
Senate yesterday facing off against Mike
Lee of Utah
doj's announced charges against 34
individuals for blocking access to or
vandalizing abortion clinics and there
have been over 81 reported attacks on
pregnancy centers 130 attacks on
Catholic churches since the leak of the
Dobbs decision and only two individuals
have been charged so how do you explain
this disparity we apply the law equally
um I will say you are quite right there
are many more prosecutions with respect
uh to the blocking of the uh of the
abortion centers but that is generally
because they are those actions are taken
in uh with photography at the time
during the daylight and seeing the
person who did it is quite easy
those who are attacking the Pregnancy
Resources centers which is a hard thing
to do are doing this at night in the
dark
okay in case you didn't follow that we
quote apply the law equally we just
can't for some reason manage to
investigate crimes that occur after dark
it's the Sundown rule well known in
legal circles
it's hard to believe that Merrick
Garland actually said that in a senate
hearing until you remember that of
course he will say anything and he does
we're not persecuting Christians they'll
tell you then he'll send the FBI after
Mark Houck howk is a pro-life lay
preacher who is praying outside an
abortion clinic when a pro-abortion
extremist harassed his 12-year-old son
so as any father would how shoved the
man out of his son's face that's what
happened it was not a crime we know that
because no local prosecutor pursued it
and it is certainly without question not
a federal felony to push a lunatic out
of your 12 year old son's face
lender Merrick Garland it is now a
felony almost a year after that happened
Garland sent armed men to arrest Mark
Houk in front of his family
on September 23rd about 6 45 in the
morning
that's uh when those 20 so so called
agents full SWAT gear uh heavily armored
vest ballistic Shields helmets uh
battering ram banged on my door
yesterday Josh Hawley asked Garland to
explain that behavior the utterly
indefensible totalitarian behavior and
Merrick Garland of course in his
soft-spoken way was delighted to defend
it
let's take a look at the hardened
criminals that your justice department
sent these armed agents to go terrorize
on that morning here they are here they
are at Mass
here's the seven children
with Mr Houck and his wife he has
offered to turn himself in
and this is who you go to terrorize you
are the Attorney General give me your
answer do you think that it was
objectively reasonable and they followed
your guidelines
in sending 20 to 30 armed agents to
terrorize these people yes or no the
facts I have which are those presented
by the FBI are not consistent with your
description so you think it was
reasonable
I'm saying the facts are not as you
describe you use an unbelievable show of
force with guns that I just know
liberals usually decry
we're supposed to hate long guns and
assault style weapons you're happy to
deploy them against Catholics and
innocent children
he doesn't care he's got no soul
obviously and if anything Josh hawley's
description is too narrow it's not just
Catholics that mayor Garland is targeted
with Force it's anybody who expresses a
belief in biblical Christianity in
public but it is true that Catholics do
seem to be getting a disproportionate
share of federal law enforcement
attention under Joe Biden the FBI as you
may notice drafted a memo claiming that
radical traditional Catholics are
somehow a national security threat
presumably because they tend to pray
outside of abortion clinics in March of
2021 Paul Vaughn and 10 others were
peacefully praying at an abortion clinic
in Tennessee they didn't damage any
property they hurt no one more than a
year after they dared to do that to pray
mayor Garland sent the FBI to terrorize
Vaughn and his 11 children at their home
but if you're not going to let me then
I'll just no I want to know why you were
banging on my door with a gun
[Applause]
you're not gonna tell me anything
I tried no you didn't yes I did you did
not try
you have to wonder when you see a tape
like that where are so-called Christian
leaders
where's Russell Moore and all the other
breastfeeding Christians as that happens
as the U.S government cracks down on
Christianity on prayer
silent
Paul Vaughn and his co-conspirators now
face more than a decade in prison
meanwhile just in case you want to know
what the scale is for punishment the
department of justice under Joe Biden
let half the rioters go who tried to
torch a courthouse in Oregon no charges
whatsoever of 99 cases that the Portland
U.S attorney brought over that
Courthouse siege for crimes like
assaulting Federal officers and civil
disorder
more than 47 were dropped by doj the
most serious penalties for most of the
defendants who pleaded guilty turned out
to be community service
so the doj and numeric ground absolves
Joe Biden voters of actual terrorism
while doing everything they can to
terrify humiliate and Destroy people who
pray in public
they're targeting specifically anyone
who is religious humilling them in front
of their children now why are they doing
this
well because on some level all
governments hate religious people
because it's competition and
revolutionary governments totalitarian
governments go after religious people
first it happened in the French
Revolution it happened in the bolshuk
revolution and it's happening now
that's why parents who dare to complain
about their children being sexually
indoctrinated and openly sexualized or
attacked in some cases by the doj
again you can see why young people
raised to believe that God is in charge
are much harder for the government to
control as they grow up they won't
worship the government
but by contrast if a child is raised to
be a narcissist someone who thinks well
I can change my gender he will grow up
confused weak and reliant on the people
in charge of the state it's a very
simple principle
it's why the maoist government went
after Tibetan Monks anyone who sincerely
believes in God is a threat and that is
the measure of a free country in the end
are you allowed to believe that there's
an authority higher than the people in
charge of your government that has
always been the Hallmark of America
religious liberty
it's in the First Amendment
but in Canada of course that's all
disappeared Canada has now become an
atheist totalitarian state with amazing
speed and in candidates now a crime to
object to sexualized drag shows for
children not allowed to say a word late
last month's month a pastor in Calgary
was violently thrown out of an all ages
notice for children drag queen Story
Hour for daring to object to the
sexualization of children watch this
[Music]
very abusive
so that's the video that's what happened
who committed the violence in that video
the guy on the ground was the pastor
before we answer the question some
context will remind you that in Canada
showing any disloyalty at all to the
Trudeau government could get your bank
account Frozen and your truck seized so
maybe you're not surprised to learn that
that man on the ground whose name is
Pastor Derek Riemer who showed profound
disrespect for Justin Trudeau's ongoing
efforts to sexualize children and
mutilate the generals of children woke
up yesterday to the police banging on
his door and telling him he was going to
be arrested
yeah you guys you can call me and we
could
you could have called me I'll be trying
to
win this morning we talk about what
happened on the weekend this evening
right
why do we need to talk about it because
you're going to be arrested for it and
charged
okay so we can we'll deal with it this
morning or I could just put warrants out
for you
Miss Jeffy calls with the service
where are all the professional
Christians you have to wonder that again
where's David French and Beth Moore and
Tim Keller and all these people were
defending Christianity as actual
Christians are being arrested for being
Christians hmm
not a word
well today Pastor Derek Greener
confirmed that a warrant was out for his
arrest for hate crimes and he was right
about that he was not overstating it
because this afternoon he was literally
arrested
thank you
seven reasons
[Applause]
so the reason you're blocking me from
using the sidewalk instruction they're
working here I'm not going to obstruct
them
don't worry I'm not gonna run I'm gonna
worry about you we're just gonna stay
out of their workspace
do you mind if I ask you what he's being
arrested for you're gonna provide your
identification pardon will you provide
your ID for you to answer the question
yeah okay uh why is he being arrested
yes warrants warrants out for his arrest
this is what happens when we go against
the Drake
wow that doesn't look like the candidate
you thought you knew all Molson and sled
dogs or some Stormtrooper and sunglasses
won't answer a question before you
provide your ID and then the pastor
sitting in a car with bars on the
windows
getting hauled away to jail for being
thrown to the ground
at drag queen Story Hour
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight